in bound by flame players a mercenary
possessed by a flame diamond the last
line of defense against the seven ice
Lords and their dead army bikes involved
my flame our dynamic but also extremely
tactical you will develop three combat
styles to three skill trees the
unyielding warrior uses swords axes and
war hammers to inflict heavy damage
knock enemies back and break their
defenses the stealthy Ranger uses dual
wield daggers to snap enemies in the
back and pin their ranks before locking
them in a fast-paced combat style that
favors raw damage skilled Rangers will
command time itself obliterating their
foes in the blink of an eye
the Pyromancer channels the firing
powers of the demon curl fireballs light
your weapon on fire invoke flame spirits
and more
explosive traps in crossbows will let
you ambush
tougher enemies and keep them at bay
your enemies have many forms each with
their own strengths attack patterns and
behaviors some deal elemental damage
inflicted shoot from a distance or close
in for heavier damage adapt your tactic
on the fly toggle between warrior and
rogue stances to use their unique skills
and strengths craft your method and
armor to optimize their effectiveness
against your current enemies increase
your damage potential with effects such
as critical damage poison a chance to
interrupt enemies and more your chosen
companion will also be a decisive
requirement for victory you need a
defensive healer and unyielding tank an
aggressive sorcerer or an illusive
Archer the toughest enemies will require
coordination discipline and skill to be
vanquished
the ice Lords will not give you a second
chance so do not falter the punishment
for failure
is death